Red Bull.
It made this guy a
$15 billion fortune.
But the recipe for his
success wasn't just
sugar,
carbonated water,
caffeine and
whatever that is.
There was another
major innovation.
Dietrich Mateschitz was
Austria's richest man
when he died in October,
and he and his team
managed to turn Red Bull
into so much more
than just an energy drink.
One of the very clever
things they've done is
turn Red Bull into a story brand.
They tell stories.
And so one of the things they did
was a light on events,
and in particular extreme sports,
things like cliff diving
or mountain biking.
These weren't terribly
expensive to back
because they were
comparatively little known.
And yet Red Bull has
made them big
and produced a lot of content
that they can then further
promote the brand with.
Whether snowboarders,
space jumps or, more recently,
owning soccer and
Formula 1 racing teams,
Red Bull has spread its
marketing tentacles
more deeply into sport than
any brand before.
And Mateschitz got lucky
because the approach
coincided with the rise
of social media
and digital video.
Rather than paying
for newspaper or TV ads,
videos of extreme
sports could go viral
at little to no extra cost,
and his brand was
splashed all over it.
That's what really gave
Red Bull wings.